I say I'm a neat freak my person that
I'm just meeting is like oh why are you
a neat freak when people give you the
reason why when they say because it's a
huge persuasion word but like you can
cut someone in line and say hey I need
to cut you in line because I have a cat
it works still three quarters of the
time as soon as you say because they say
oh there's a Justified reason cool they
don't even really listen to it most
times when people try and explain a
behavior or explain a character trait or
explain a label they describe to
themselves they just basically say hey I
am neat because gobbledygo they
basically just make up a reason that
they have no idea it could be because of
their mom it could be because of their
dad or maybe they were born already
hating it because of brain wiring who
knows and so the question is is it
important is it knowable is it important
yes is it knowable no so why does it
matter a lot of times you can get much
closer to the truth by just saying I am
neat or I tend to be neat people are
like why and you can just say I don't
know